one difficulty which should be avoided
comes from mixing up the speculative
with the rats eosin native methods so
that what is said of the subject at one
time signifies its notion at another
time merely its predicate or accidental
property the one method interferes with
the other and only a philosophical
exhibition that rigidly excludes the
usual way of relating the parts of a
proposition could achieve the goal of
plasticity
this is a very short paragraph and I
don't think that there's an awful lot
that has to be said about it at this
point some of what Hegel is doing here
is just sort of summarizing and review
for us but you know it's worth hitting
on very quickly just to reinforce these
notions in our mind before that there's
there's a term that he's using that I
want to clarify in part because it's
come to mean there it's come to have a
lot of different associations for us
then it would have had this time and
that word is plastic and and it's a
direct you know cognate to the German
plastic here and when when we you know
late moderns or thinking of plastic what
comes to mind this is a great example
actually for Hegel because in Hegel's
time it would have meant something
that's an adjective which describes a
certain kind of state for us it's
actually become the substance it's
become substantial I'd this is one of
those examples of something becoming
actual and then attaining a kind of
universality for us and a concreteness
that it didn't have for Hegel they would
talk for example about the plastic art
sculpture is being a prime example what
is the sculptor doing you know you think
of the marble sculptor who's you know
chipping away at things but thinking
part of the one who's working in clay so
you're molding things you're you're
bending them that's what it is to be
plastic so when people started
experimenting with the kinds of
substances that we call plastic which is
you know ubiquitous part of our life
there's plastic in my buttons on my
shirt there's some bits of plastic I'm
sure in this somewhere along the line
maybe the varnish is in some way some
plastic you know we're surrounded by
plastic as substances and in all
different kinds of forms we're used to
being sloths we're used to being super
hard everything in between why is it
called plastic well because it's
moldable that's what makes it so
versatile for us that's why it's become
such a
a major part of our environment actually
something that's destroying our
environment this without like physical
natural environment you can do molding
with plastic you can make it into the
kind of shape that you want so how is
Hegel bringing he's talking about our
minds having that kind of plasticity and
a philosophical exposition that rigidly
excludes the usual way of relating the
parts of a proposition that would attain
a goal of plasticity we're not going to
have that in many cases this is an ideal
and the ideal would be to be completely
moldable completely shapeable so that's
when he's meaning there that's that's a
good thing to keep in mind now he's
talking about how this object is
understood and two different modes of
thinking these are by some ways
translated here as modes but you can
think of it as methods of rasa ratsy of
some native or argumentative approach
you know basil urine that we've seen
this used a lot this is the typical sort
of Enlightenment way it's also the sort
of gotcha reasoning kind of way it's
it's often quite negative remember it
can lapse into vanity or futility it's
something that's always available to us
we can always criticize we can always
point out problems we can always you
know draw conclusions we can always
reason things out but that doesn't mean
that we're always getting at the reality
or the truth of things sometimes it
leads us astray then we have a
speculative or dialectical way of
approaching these things and they're
both working with subjects that both
working with rheumatica subjects and so
how does the rats you know it's a native
approach it connects it to predicates it
connects it to accidental properties
predicated of it you know I am here in
this place at this time I am also on
your video screen at whatever time
you're watching this whatever could be
years from now that you're watching this
those are accidental properties they're
not they're not really essential another
thing that you could put over here is
that speculative deals with the essences
now that which really matters that which
is really at the heart of things that
which changes things that's that which
is most relevant the notion the big rift
the concept that the dialectic works
with that is to be found you know in the
speculative way of looking at the
subject so the goal is to turn this
stuff over here when we run into it into
this or to like bring it in there but
sometimes it has to just consists in
saying no sorry you missed it you didn't
get it your your reasoning stuff out but
you're just not getting it yeah you know
I mentioned a couple times in recent
videos that some of this can apply to
the way I handle my comments when
somebody just goes like totally off the
rails oftentimes I don't even bother to
engage with them you know why cuz life
is short and because I want to think
things out first they're good you know
if they're caught up in this maybe it's
time for them to approach it you know
somebody else down the line you know and
they can see the futility of this and
they want something more that's really
all there is to be said about this
section I think
as a matter of fact nonon speculative
thinking also has its valid rights which
are disregarded in the speculative way
of stating a proposition
thus ablation of the form of the
proposition must not happen only in an
immediate manner through the mere
content of the proposition on the
contrary this opposite movement must
find explicit expression it must not
just be the inward inhibition mentioned
above this return of the notion into
itself must be set forth this movement
which constitutes what formerly the
proof was supposed to accomplish is the
dialectical movement of the proposition
itself this alone is the speculative in
act and only the expression of this
movement is a speculative exhibition
exposition as a proposition the
speculative is only the internal
inhibition and the non-essential return
of the essence into itself hence we
often find philosophical excope
expositions referring us to this inner
intuition and in this way they evade the
systematic exposition of the dialectical
movement of the proposition which we
have demanded the proposition should
Express what the truth is but
essentially the true is subject as such
it is merely the dialectical movement
this course that generates itself going
forth from and returning into itself in
not a speculative cognition proof
constitutes this side of expressed
inward Ness but once the dialectic has
been separated from proof the notion of
philosophical demonstration has been
lost
looking at section 65 it's interesting
that that Hegel starts out by talking
about non speculative thinking and there
you know keep in mind what we're
covering not just you know raisin ear
and the the argumentative or rat suits
and rats a negative approach but also
appeals to intuition common sense
picture thinking all of these have their
their rights all of them have a certain
legitimacy to them all of them have a
proper function
it's just when they get substituted for
philosophy that we have a problem and so
he's going to say here he doesn't
actually use the word responsibility but
I'm using this in part because we've got
this this conception that rights of
another often entail responsibilities on
one's own part so speculative thinking
bears certain responsibilities for
itself for those who are engaging in it
but also in relation to non-speculative
forms of thinking and he gives you a
number of different points that I've
summarized here
he says the sublation of the form of the
proposition must not happen only in an
immediate manner through the mere
content of the proposition so that's one
that's important to dwell on so blasian
is this term I'll cave on sublation is
is just you know an English way of
trying to sort of get the cognate across
what is now cable we've talked about
this this is a really central Hegelian
concept ow hey bong means a sort of
transcendence that incorporates what is
being transcended or at least
incorporates its most important moments
or parts and brings about a greater a
higher type of unity a whole something
that is is you might say not able to be
completely viewed from the previous
position what you know the previous
shape of consciousness what's been
transcended in this case is the
proposition so how has that been
transcended how has
sublated it's been shown to contain the
the possibilities for a kind of
distinction than a kind of unification
the subject disappearing into the
predicate also being found in the
predicate this non vicious circularity
that we've talked about already so all
that has to be done he says not in an
immediate manner it could happen
immediately but in a mediate manner that
is in an unmediated way without sort of
thinking it through without making it
explicit what's going on so he says on
the contrary this opposite movement must
find explicit expression it must not be
the inward inhibition mentioned above
this return into the of the notion into
itself must be set forth so if we're
dealing with a subject that in its
relation to a predicate becomes a notion
a concept of the Grif a self moving
entity whose development we can sit back
and observe or perhaps which is taking
place within us perhaps were involved in
that notion in its development if that's
the case then what's going to happen is
the notion is going to self alter it's
going to self other and it's going to
reincorporate what has been other dinh
that process that's the process of
negativity of determinate negation so
the return of the notion into itself
must be set forth you saying we have to
actually make it explicit we can't just
sort of say well I'm just gonna sit back
and watch we have to document it you
might you might say this movement he
says which constitutes what formerly the
proof was supposed to accomplish that's
worth dwelling on proof you notice we're
going back now to thinking in terms of
this you know either
reasoning way of approaching things or
the the one that was modeled on
mathematics mathematical cognition
mathematical style proof was supposed to
yield us something that we could be
completely confident
but it's also important because of all
the the back stuff you remember back in
geometry class if you guys still do
proofs in geometry class do you ever get
docked for not showing your work and you
say well it doesn't matter all we're
interested in is the result well no the
proof is the the stuff that leads to the
result so what a speculative thinking
have in place of that it has the
documentation the the analysis the
watching the making explicit of what's
actually going on in the you know
transition from one shape of
consciousness to another one in the
dialectic so he says this is the
dialectical movement of the proposition
itself this alone is the speculative an
act and only the expression of this
movement is a speculative exposition now
here he's talking about at the level of
the proposition but we can also talk
about larger levels as well that this is
going to go for but notice that means
that we can also sort of bear down to
the proposition itself the sort of
developments that are taking place
historically are not something that are
totally beyond our grasp we can express
them in propositions we can express them
propositional ly in terms of subject and
predicate but we have to be prepared for
some sort of dynamic interplay between
those so he says as a proposition the
speculative is only the internal
inhibition and non existential return of
the essence into itself what does what
does that mean here he's talking about
remember back a few paragraphs before
how consciousness gets sort of stymied
when the predicate assumes the
importance and the subject kind of
disappears into the predicate and then
we have to rediscover the the subject
within the predicate we we rediscover
the predicate as having a substantiality
to itself so he says what is the result
of this well we often find philosophical
expositions making appeal to enter
intuition and why would they make that
he'll remember it higgles generally
going to be seeing intuition was a bad
thing but in this case maybe he would
have good grounds for saying well you
just have to like you know you have to
have the right intuition of it you gotta
have developed far enough there's a
certain truth to that here but it
doesn't go far enough why well because
there's an arbitrariness to intuition
that we've already seen but also because
when you appeal to the inner you're not
being fully dialectical you're not fully
taking speculative thinking where it
needs to go he says they have aid the
systematic exposition of the dialectical
movement of the proposition which we've
demanded so you can't just appeal to
intuition you have to be systematic and
you have to be systematic in setting out
that's what an exposition is you're
laying everything out and saying how
everything is connected to everything
else so he says the proposition should
Express with the truths but essentially
the true is subject this is not
something new at this point as such it's
merely the dialectical movement the
course that generates itself going forth
from and returning to itself in the non
speculative proposition proof is what
we're looking for does that mean that
we're not looking for proof at all the
Weisse demonstration in this no proof
does he have some value he says once the
dialectic has been separated from proof
the notion of philosophical
demonstration has been lost what does
that mean that means that we do have to
be engaged in a process where we if
we're the ones who are in the privileged
position able to look at this panorama
of history in a synoptic fashion and see
the development taking place we can't
just say that to each other is sort of
an Illuminati or intelligentsia we have
to be able to explain this to other
rational subjects so that they can also
participate in that community of inquiry
and they can see
what's going on if we're not doing that
something is falling short something is
not fully being developed and we should
actually begin to be a little bit
suspect about our own position that
perhaps it contains some idiosyncrasies
some eccentricities that it's not as
fully developed as it ought to be in
some ways the test of whether you know
if we go back to Plato the test of
whether you truly know something is
whether you're able to teach it to
somebody else it's kind of funny because
you know there's an old adage those who
you know know something do it those who
don't know it teach Hegel would say
that's completely wrong in order to say
actually teach effectively you actually
need to know what it is that you're
teaching about and part of what teaching
really is is taking what is inner and
making it outer making it exterior
laying it out for others taking the
esoteric and making it exoteric you can
say so this is a very important passage
because he's again stressing the rights
of non speculative thinking by stressing
what it is that speculative thinking
ought to do how it ought to conduct
itself
here we should bear in mind that the
dialectical movement likewise has
propositions for his parts or elements
the difficulty just indicate it seems
therefore to recur perpetually and to be
inherent in the very nature of
philosophical exhibition exposition this
is like what happens in ordinary proof
where the reasons given under themselves
and in need of further reasons and so on
ad infinitum this pattern of giving
reasons and stating conditions belongs
to that method of proof which differs
from the dialectical movement and
belongs therefore to external cognition
as regards a dialectical movement itself
its element is the one notion it thus
has a content which is in its own self
subject through and through thus no
content occurs which functions as an
underlying subject nor receives its
meaning as a predicate the proposition
as it is stands merely as an empty form
apart from the self that is sensuously
intuited or represented it is above all
the name is name that designates the
pure subject the empty unit without
thought content for this reason it may
be expedient for example to avoid the
name god
since this word is not immediately also
a notion but rather the proper name the
fixed point of rest of the underlying
subject whereas on the other hand for
example being or the one singularity the
subject etc themselves at what at once
suggests concepts even if speculative
truths are affirmed of this subject
their content lacks the imminent notion
because it is present merely in the form
of a passive subject with the result
that such truths readily assume the form
of mere edification from this side to
the habit of expressing the speculative
predicate in the form of a proposition
and not as notion and essence creates a
difficulty that can be increased or
diminished through the very way in which
philosophy is expounded in keeping with
our insight into the nature of
speculation the X of exposition should
preserve the dialectical form and should
admit nothing except insofar as it is
comprehended in terms
the notion and is the notion
here in section 66 Hegel is bringing
together several threads that he has
previously developed in some of the
earlier paragraphs and he's going to
bring us to one of these important crux
points you could you could summarize it
by saying that philosophy speculative
philosophy dialectical philosophy
included cannot dispense with the fact
that it's rooted within language and
everything that language then ends up
ringing and so you know if it's going to
work it's going to have to work by
transforming the linguistic elements the
linguistic parts the linguistic
resources than it has before it rather
than just taking them for granted as the
conditions that it has to work under in
this respect you could say in a way that
Hegel's phenomenology is the the
opposite of something like ordinary
language philosophy which developed out
of a reaction against idealism in
Britain which had been influenced by
Hegel which took you know the limits of
languages being the limits of my world
whose [ __ ] constraints tracked hottes
formulation Hegel is is holding out hope
for us being able to to think through
how we're using language so he says the
dialectical movement has propositions
for its parts and its elements so the
difficulty that we've just indicated
seems to recur perpetually and to be
inherent in the very nature of
philosophical exposition here is going
to say something about ordinary proof or
proof that's not dialectical and some of
the problems with it that were pointed
out by skeptics in the ancient world and
which we can still say our problems
today but I also before we go into that
I want to point out something else you
might object to Hegel and you might
object to the worries about this you
know propositions having subject
predicate form you could say well not
all language is built like German or
built like the indo-european
we have languages that use that you know
there's these other you know languages
and they have their own way of parsing
up grammar and the world yeah it's very
different than our own and it's you know
just as original or relation to the
world and so maybe we could model it on
those you know maybe we don't have to
have substances and subjects and
predicates and you know there's a
certain truth to that but I want you to
realize something whenever you say that
sort of thing
likewise whenever you talk about what
what lies beyond language mystical
insights that can't be communicated
you're still using language and you're
still using the kind of language that we
in the West have come you know we've
become accustomed to using and it's
pretty hard to get away from it because
if you want to say you know there's
other languages that are not subject
predicate form dependent and we should
be using those notice what you're doing
there's other languages there's your
subject and they're not subject
predicate dependent you've just done a
subject predicate thing all right so
you're replicating the same problem
you're just pushing a little bit deeper
and we could go on and on about that
that sort of thing but you know maybe
maybe later on so he talks about
ordinary proofing he says the reasons
given themselves are needed for the
reasons and so on and infinitum you can
sing this about you know logical
deductions well why do we have to accept
the rules of inference that are used in
logical deductions you know why do we
have to accept the the law of the
excluded middle can you provide me a
proof for that you know a certain point
you have to actually call a stop to that
sort of thing or also you're going to be
stuck in skepticism forever so he says
this pattern of giving reasons and
stating conditions belong so that method
of proof which differs from the
dialectical movement belongs to the
external cognition like a cognition that
knows the thing but stays outside of it
that doesn't penetrate into the
phenomenon itself as regards the
dialectical movement its element is the
one notion he said it has a content
which is its own self
subject through and through now how does
it connect up with what he's saying here
he's not making that fully explicit he
says no content occurs which functions
as an underlying subject nor receives
its meaning as a predicate the
proposition as it stands is merely an
empty forum that doesn't actually sound
very good but if you think about what
happens in the phenomenology what's been
going on up to this point what's what's
being promised to happen in these
propositions which are part of the
dialectical movement where we're moving
from one proposition to the next and we
also have this interior dialectic taking
place when the subject is getting lost
in the predicate and then getting
refound in the predicate there's this
return to itself you can say that
there's this this level of sort of
complexity where this is getting assumed
into this and then coming back to it
this is getting assumed into this and
coming back to it so that is part of
what Hegel means by by notion this
dynamic self developing complex process
that's going to yield as a subject that
runs through all of us so this subject
here can't be strictly identified with
the subject here the subject here the
subject here it's something that's a bit
deeper and guess guess what that subject
is well it's the it's the notion itself
go a little bit further it's us it's
also us the D knowing the thinking the
acting the appropriating subject as well
so now he's going to take a shift in in
the second paragraph of this this
section he says apart from the self that
essentially sensuously intuitive
represented right so I what is what is
the self that's sensuously intuitive
representative I can look at the mirror
and I can see I'm wearing this tie I can
you know see that I have lines in my
face because I'm 44 years old it's a
book all that name that designates the
pure subject the empty unit without
thought content
he's always talking about God well let's
let's stop for a second let's use
something like this piece of chalk
worn down halfway through chalk that
term chalk let's write it up here
interesting way this is the elects the
the net lexical but this is the visual
equivalent of an onomatopoeia right
where the the name sounds like the thing
like if I say squat right oh I wrote
chalk out of chalk on the chalkboard
right so there's a little funny
reflexivity there to it but that word
chalk although it's made of chalk is not
the same thing as the piece of chalk and
if you want to know what the piece of
chalk is you probably should do less of
paying attention to you know the letters
and more looking at this actual thing
we're looking at how the letters were
made of this substance that we call Cha
we could say the same thing many other
things freedom for example when we start
predicating things of freedom so he says
for this reason it may be expedient to
avoid the name God why why should we
avoid the name God because we have no
idea what the hell it means at least at
the beginning by the end of the
phenomenology we actually you know the
penultimate chapter of the phenomenology
is called religion and we're gonna learn
an awful lot about what God it is and
it's gonna turn out that we have a very
intimate connection with God I don't
want to give away the seek you know the
secret of the ending if you haven't
already read about it in encyclopedia or
something like that but I'll say this
Stanley Rosen says that if Hegel was an
Orthodox Christian you certainly
belonged to a church with only one
member that is himself and I think
that's pretty accurate to say about it
so he'll says at the beginning we should
avoid the word guy why because the word
is not immediately a notion but rather
the proper name the fixed point of rest
of the underlying subject people have
said all sorts of things about God
throughout history and the name is kind
of like a worn-out coin at this point
we're not quite sure what it means or
what it can be exchanged for
as a subject what are other things that
we can talk about instead of God it says
being the one singularity the subject
what if the others of those who have
over God so they at the very beginning
suggest concepts they suggest notions
they suggest things that we can start
wrapping our head around whereas God has
become sort of an empty name which can
obtain some content later on but we
can't use that as a beginning point here
you see like a radical split between
philosophy and some sort of you know
theology although what Hegel is doing
could be understood as a type of
theology as well I don't want anyone to
get upset and object that so he says
even a speculative truths are affirm to
this subject their content lacks the
imminent notion because its present
merely in the form of a passive subject
with the result that such truths readily
assume the form of me ratification a lot
of our God talk according to Hegel
doesn't really amount to much it may
make us feel warm and fuzzy God is loved
that's not actually teaching us
something but if we say being or the
singularity is love now we're actually
starting to dig our heels in and sink
our teeth into some sort of meat you
could say so he says from this side to
the habit of expressing the speculative
predicate in the form of a proposition
and not as notion and essence creates a
difficulty and this difficulty is not an
absolutely insurmountable one but it's
one that can be increased or diminished
through the very way in which philosophy
is expounded if for example we were
trying to reduce Hegel to a textbook
we'd be increasing the difficulty
because the textbook is going to use the
tired old subject predicate predicates
really just mean accidental qualities we
already know everything to begin with
I'm just communicating the knowledge
there's no experimentation there's no
excitement
there's no witnessing you know truth
itself developing over time happen
with the textbook what about a
commentary what about what we're doing
right here good question
I leave that one up to you to think
about are we doing something that's just
sort of trotting up old formulas Hegel
means this Hegel means that you know
this is equivalent to that and that's
equivalent to this so therefore we can
have it all set up and it all makes
sense is that what we're doing right now
or are we trying to follow along with
the dialectical development that he is
tracing out for us and seeing it not as
something that just was traced out once
and for all in 1807 but something that
we could ourselves participate in and
get to know anew I hope it's the latter
so he says it creates a difficulty that
can be increased or diminished through
the very way in which philosophy is
expounded in keeping with our insight
into the nature of speculation the
exposition should preserve the
dialectical form why it should admit
nothing except insofar as its
comprehended in terms of the notion and
is the notion why well because if the
form doesn't to some degree resemble the
content then we've got a weird sort of
dichotomy here where we're trying to do
all this you know radical stuff over
here with the content but we're going to
do it in the same old tired way now what
are the implications for this the
implications for this is that Hegel is
doing philosophy in a new way not just
by approaching new topics or you know
dealing with the topics in a different
way but by presenting it in a different
way by laying it out for us in a way
that demands some changes on our own
part having to do with our the way in
which we're accustomed to thinking about
things